ready to eat sushi salad and spring  rolls are being voluntarily recalled  over fears of listeria contamination the  Fuji food products are sold in 31 states  in Washington DC they were shipped to  several different retailers including  Trader Joe's 7-eleven and Walgreens the  products are packed in plastic with most  having some buy dates of November 22nd  to December 6th Fuji says consumers  should throw out any of the food in  their possession no illnesses have been  reported to see the full FDA recall list  visit CBS news.com potentially this is  where nobody has it in their possession  right now people might be looking in  their trash from yesterday's lunch and  be like I hope it wasn't that one yeah  it cost it because it's potentially  fatal to people with very weak immune  system all right